countries around the world are rushing
to use technology to slow the spread of
the coronavirus some governments are
tracking citizens with the help of apps
drones and other high-tech methods but
critics warn the surveillance may go too
far Roxana Saberi in London has been
looking into the measures in China a
drone picks out perpetrators in public
ordering this man to wear a mask in
South Korea special cameras expose
anyone with a fever and in Tunisia a
police robot questioned suspected
violators of the country's lockdown all
high-tech tools designed to slow the
spread of koban 19 sort of form putting
in my address my my ID number and all
that for them to track me my love Shia a
student at American University in
Washington DC says when he flew home to
Taiwan last month authorities told him
to quarantine at home for two weeks they
verbally told me that you know your
phone will be satellite tracked he just
didn't realize how closely my phone ran
out of battery for about 15 minutes I
plugged it in but by then there was
already two police officers knocking at
my door
what do you think about that level of
tracking and enforcement some of my
friends think it's perfectly fine at the
same time you know it's a little scary
knowing that you know they have this
capability it's a concern raised by
privacy advocates like Estelle masse
government do need data to find this
great of the virus but knowing at what
time I I go to the shop if I'm not
infected knowing who I may be meeting
here is not relevant the extent of
surveillance varies from country to
country in Europe voluntary apps track
people's symptoms and this one in Israel
even alerts users if they've come into
contact with someone who's infected now
Google and Apple say they're building
similar contact tracing technology into
smartphones and move president Trump
says his administration is looking into
already US officials are turning to tech
companies to tap into people's digital
day
to see if they're practicing social
distancing here in London for example
data gathered by Google shows where the
UK's lockdown is working visits to shops
are down 84% to workplaces 61 but visits
to parks where police have had to send
sunbathers home have dropped only 15
percent that is very useful data and it
is very easy to keep that anonymous the
next step would be when the government
starts to track individuals we don't
know when that will happen
CBS News contributor Nick Thompson how
unprecedented is this use of technology
I don't think we've ever had a moment
where people are willing to say okay you
can use my phone to identify every
person I've been near and I'm ok with
that that is new but everything about
coronavirus is new this contact tracing
technology is not yet widely used in the
US and so far it's up to you to download
an app and share your details now these
tools are useful but as they become more
widespread they'll raise more questions
about privacy
Anthony yeah the technology is amazing
but the surveillance is kind of scary
Roxana Saberi in London Thank You Roxana